let's let's let's talk about the uh the
something else that's that's that's
funny we'll have a good laugh today we
have this tweet from suraj hashmi
uh cnn plus it's a collection of uh of
images posted by sarah cinnamon plus
tweets today a historic day for us as we
launch cnn plus our streaming platform
that brings you the stories of our world
anytime you want
what
what was a recent news worth newsworthy
first for you now a quick question did
cnn get their own emoji on twitter
oh they paid for that right right right
now here we go thank you siraj for this
the very next day
breaking cnn plus employees bracing for
layoffs possibly as soon as may amid
projections of lackluster sales of new
streaming channel c of new streaming
channel cnn employees say new streaming
channel could be merged into larger
discovery plus as early as may unless
subscriptions pick up uh and then
pick up 130 i don't know check this out
check this out though from sagar and
jetty
cnn plus already showing no confidence
in their product throwing away subs at
discount rates to fake their initial
sign-up numbers shows how worthless the
product is book clubs and parenting
advice from personalities you can
already get for free on cnn garbage
cnn tell us how you really feel on day
one of cnn's new service we're offering
50 off for life
now look i understand if you know
someone does like a promo read
and the advertiser says
we'll do a discount for your audience
because we're trying to attract new
people to come and sign up this is day
one of cnn no confidence well this is
what's really funny okay
is i want you to just imagine something
there was a table like this one that
we're at right now and there were a
bunch of people around it and they all
thought it would be a really good idea
and they thought that people would pay
for
access to more brian stelter and more
i can't even say with that and more don
lemon okay
these people are crazy there's no other
way to put it they are absolutely off
their rocker insane nobody wants to pay
for this and anybody who does
that's going to be a list that you want
in the future because they belong in a
mental institution okay i i genuinely
wonder how many people that signed up
for their service though so i'm
wondering if they'll release those
numbers or if they have i don't know oh
no way
if it's really low they probably won't
do it i i just want to point out to all
of our members at timcast.com
you get a variety of shows mostly you'll
get monday through thursday our members
only show it's a half an hour long or so
sometimes longer because we'll have
people talking about crazy stuff and we
go for a long time and we also have the
green room show which is uh fridays it's
in the in the green room hanging out
with these personalities we had you know
jeremy boring we also have conspiracy
shows and stuff that are more seasonal
we don't produce nearly as much as cnn
does you know their their thing is but
people actually want to watch you that's
the difference
it's true but the point i'm making is
it's ten bucks for teamcast.com because
that's about what we need to charge to
for one you know produce all these shows
and continue to expand you know maybe
once once you have weight substantially
more subscribers you lower the price you
know it can go down the more people who
sign up
cnn lowered the price before anybody
even had a chance to sign up but one
member at timcast.com
is creating the cultural influence of
three members of cnn cnn plus 100 so
that that's what i think is significant
here and they're struggling and they're
going to be laying people off and you
know what good riddance to uh to a bad
product well i think i told lydia this
you know so i've been on you know pretty
much every big show i've been on tucker
and all these other places the one show
that i've been on where i've had more
people come up to me than anything
is actually this one that seems crazy to
me it is weird and i'd never expected it
you know i knew we'd get some you know
because you always get some from
different shows
i always thought tucker would be the
biggest you know because he has just a
really rabid audience and i've been on
there a lot so i would especially think
that it would be from there but there's
so many people who just randomly come up
to me and are like hey i saw you on tim
pool he is amazing the show's amazing i
love lydia
and then they leave you out yeah
it's just like that long-haired guy it's
the form it's long form because you can
sit here and people get to know you yeah
they're like they know you like i think
that that actually might be what it is
is the recognition long term if you sit
with somebody for an hour you remember
them if you really get into a
conversation with them but if you sit
with them for a four minute hit on
tucker or something like that if you're
interested maybe you remember if you're
not then it's just another talking head
on tv and i'm told uh it's it's one of
the reasons why i stopped
going on fox yeah you know they started
hitting me up more and more and then
after a certain point i was just like
why yeah i mean no offense not trying to
drag them because the guys who were
trying to book me were nice but it's
just like i honestly have no incentive
to to to do a three-minute spot on your
show the first uh 20 30 years of my life
was in the entertainment industry as an
actor for age 15 to 30 i was like i'm
gonna get to the oscars one day and i'm
gonna i'm gonna have my moment of three
minutes where i get to tell the world
the right info that i need to deliver
and then youtube appeared and all of a
sudden it was like every day is an oscar
speech this completely the industry's
completely shifted yeah it's just
totally and this brings me back to the
cnn whoever's running this business is
not savvy either they they put like they
gambled on this they gambled the
livelihoods of their employees on this
on and on on extra chris wallace content
okay
chris wallace but think about being
chris wallace yeah and being so
inept that you were like going to cnn
plus is a good idea well this is
actually you know i feel almost a little
bad for him because this is one of those
generational things like at his age some
you know younger executive comes and
says we're going to do this cool new
streaming platform and you know he's
like well
that's the new thing i mean i guess
people are doing streaming so sure and
has no concept of the fact that nobody's
going to pay for this from cnn plus yeah
but nobody cares
fox that's the problem oh yes 100
spineless losers he's alright you know i
could tolerate
opinion but when you're calling for
insurrection
but when you have certain opinions then
i can't tolerate it anymore so one of
the responses to suraj was
about cnn plus that sucks are we
celebrating this people are losing jobs
yes we are because the people who would
work at cnn the people that were exposed
by project veritas the ones who are
saying we don't do news anymore they
want to destroy your life these are
people who are like don't blame me i
know cnn's bad but i'll certainly take a
pitchfork and chase you out of town if
they tell me to no i'm i'm sorry dude
when when we talk about cops when we
talk about policing and i say i'm not
going to defend cops when they're
shutting down mom and pop shops over
covid the police departments don't
deserve my support if they're going to
arrest some lady over you know opening
your salon or a guy for having opening
his gym you think i'm gonna sit here and
stand for the people at cnn who are
either willfully or ignorantly
supporting that that crooked corrupt bs
no way dude they should all be fired
yeah they you know i have
no sympathy no empathy for that crowd
they get fired i'm gonna celebrate every
single time um on a side note in our
area down in tennessee our officers did
not allow any of that coveted stuff to
happen period and that is the reason why
you're seeing this massive exodus out of
blue states and out of areas where the
police do allow this stuff in our areas
the police protected the people which is
what they're supposed to do you know and
they protected our rights i think that's
an important distinction too because
i've been like you know i've said you
know abolish the police fine you know
democrats if they want it they can get
they can take whatever they want i'll
call their bluff and with the cops we're
shutting down people over covet you know
what fine get rid of them but i should
issue a clarification what we're really
talking about is the problem the
problematic police are in big cities
that are run by 100
radicals in a lot of these places and
blue state troopers 100 i mean you see
some of them reporting on their own
officers for just going and doing
investigative work you know that's
happened in a number of cases where
they're running something down and
they're like no you can't do that we
haven't had a whole lot of conversations
about abolishing the south dakota police
who you know
didn't go in and and
harass people and shut them down in fact
south dakota did a pretty good job and
in florida they put up billboards i
think there was one out here that said
you know it was basically like come be a
cop in florida so you know we're in
we're in western maryland and we're in
west virginia but over on the maryland
side they're like hey if you don't want
to be a cop here because what's going on
they come down to come on over so so the
issue really is you know what
it's not the police
it's the politics michael malus would
have some choice words there but uh yeah
it's the politics it is well no i know
you know
the sheriffs there really are making a
difference in this country are the ones
who go out there and say i want you
armed i want you to exercise your second
amendment i want you to carry i want you
to be a part of this service to the
community to make sure we live in a safe
place where i live in tennessee you
don't worry about violent crime you
don't worry about any of these issues
because number one people are worried
you might be caring but number two they
know that our sheriffs don't put up with
anything like that and beyond that when
the government comes in and intrudes and
this is the most important point when
the government oversteps
they don't say my job is to serve the
government they say my job is to serve
the people
and that is the really important
distinction that's when you go from it
being you know police to being you know
essentially state actors
and that's where i'd have a problem the
people who go and they're saying i'm
gonna go defend whatever joe biden's
edict is
even if it's illegal
that's not something i want any part in
but if you're going and you're doing
what was intended
you can't replace that you know we need
more and more of that sort of you know
outlook
yeah when cnn people just to reiterate
lose their jobs i'm not going to shed a
tear over it nope yeah i think uh when
it comes to i'll throw them a party like
a big party party and they can come and
it'll say learn to code they want like
the federal reserve's huge on job
creation programs they're all about the
job economy where you dig a hole and
then they're going to get that guy to
come fill the hole back up and then
they'll pay that kind of digger and
they'll pay you fake money and keep you
paying taxes and and owe interest so
they they make money off of your toiling
around with these jobs well that this is
at that point shattering a worthless
company is not necessarily losing yeah
you're losing jobs it might actually
benefit the society if you have a
company that's doing bad things you want
those jobs to be gone bravo sir okay
hard 20 right there from ian cnn is
damaging society they're not helping it
so when they're like we have to lay off
these people i'm just like um if you
hired somebody to go and riot with
antifa i would appreciate it if they
were laid off yeah cnn is the mental
equivalent of antifa 100 they're causing
insane political damage they're the
reason people like ron perlman smash
their face into their chest and go daddy
boy
don't say gay because the dude doesn't
actually know what's going on because he
watches cnn cnn's owned by disney right
yeah this is so disney probably no no no
no no they're not owned by this isn't it
yeah they're not owned by disney they're
not owned by
okay
yeah cnn
18 no okay yeah it's one by one uh cnn
is operated by warner media yeah yeah
it's uh espn that's owned by disney i
was getting that stuff abc all these
other companies owned by disney operated
by att so it's warner
this is like the news arm of warner of
that company so they just they just got
sold i think they just got sold to
warner right because i know there was a
recent sale
um as of
yeah because i think 18 at t owned them
yeah but att is owned by warner or no
they're owned by dish so like like
whoever sold it they got out quick they
got out at the right time
and they're just gonna subsidize it you
think warner's just gonna subsidize this
thing to death basically until it no one
until it's completely it's annihilated i
had i was wondering about this because
cnn's ratings are so abysmal i'm just
like what why would someone buy cnn i
don't get it i really don't i don't even
want the brand anymore
brand's popular though it is super
popular with like normie internationally
yes that's the issue so what happens is
uh cnn on youtube their youtube ratings
tripled from like 25 million a week to
80 million a week when the war happened
for about three weeks their viewership
were ripple well no it's regular people
who are like hey some big news thing
happened i better search cnn for it but
it's why they're motivated to make
stories happen
they go in that direction because they
love war right it helps the ratings
advertisers pay more you know good
things happen in their view
wow i mean that's very much like a
fireman getting paid to put out fires
and then end up lighting their own fires
to get paid
i mean there should not be an incentive
to make money for a news organization on
bad news did you see ryan long uh and
danny paulus chuck's bit about the
antifa window repair yeah yeah they were
like they simultaneously go out with
antifa riding and smashing windows but
then also offer our window repair
service yes yes so you know that's kind
of how it works a little bit like that
exactly well i mean they're cheerleading
at this point some of the stuff you know
we were listening um in the car um and i
think they were replaying see it was
either cnn or msnbc in the car and um
these people were totally ludicrously
pushing for war you know you couldn't be
more sort of
profane in terms of your divorcedness
from the human side of this that people
are going to have to die for this you
know but on their side of things they're
like we want to keep this going for
ratings thank you for using the word
profane i've been thinking about how
about how you don't have to use swear
words to be profane certain behaviors
and actions are pro oh they're more
profane than curse words you know they
really are if you're sitting there and
you're advocating to send a bunch of
young men and women to die in some
foreign country that they have no
business in that's profane that's more
profane than somebody using the f word
or whatever it is
that is profane because you're divorced
from the reality of war and loss and
pain that normal people feel and if
you're divorced from that you're
divorced from everything that matters
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you